welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down the Fall of the House of
Usher Mike Flanigan has been absolutely
killing out Netflix and this feels like
a culmination of all the shows and films
he's made over the last handful of years
that includes a cast 2 with us getting
lots of the actors he's worked with
before making major appearances there's
also lot of nods and Easter eggs that
point to his work and we're going to be
cheing it all down in this video was
that Ouija that Ouija board there that's
a odd to his movie Ouija origin of evil
same same actress too anyway we're going
to be breaking it all down and heavy
spoilers ahead for what we're about to
talk about the show is definitely worth
seeing unspoiled and I highly recommend
that you check it out first that's my
offer to you though this is a one-time
deal and if you still want to go ahead
let's get into The Fall of the House of
Usher 5 4 3 2 1 now like a lot of
Flanigan's work this is Loosely adapted
from some famous Source material pulling
from the Edgar alen Poe short story that
followed a narrator going out to rodri
Usher who was suffering from an illness
noticing cracks in the home we learn
rodri and his sister meline are the only
remaining members of the family meline
to has been struck down with an illness
which in the book is similar to the
deathlike trance that we see her mother
in at one point she's buried and intuned
but she ends up coming back to attack
her brother this of course gets buil
upon in the show with it being a motif
that plays off in the finale now in the
end the Nora flees the house and watches
it literally fall apart and drop into
the sea now as in the case of all of
Flanigan's work these brief Tales are
greatly expanded upon with us watching a
character named August traveling out to
rodri usha's childhood home in order to
hear about his life rodri is played by
Bruce Greenwood who worked together with
flanakin on the film Gerald's Game the
film actually pops up at roughly the 35
minute Mark during episode 6 and we see
on Netflix along with other titles now
we discovered that he could have been a
poet which may be a nod to Edgar alen
Poe himself however he went on to become
a ruthless business tycoon who's even
happy to have his wife addicted to the
opioid for positive PR here he pretty
much tells his life story and discusses
the deaths of all his family members in
which a mysterious woman was present
August is played by call Lumley and you
might recognize him from Flanigan stct
to sleep there's also another of The
Shining as well as we hear a song from
it being played at Mr
Longfellows what did you say it's the
least you could do for her that is it's
all forgot now by Ry Noble with Robert
Long Street appearing in Dr sleep and
horning of Hell House I don't I think he
was in blind manner as well but I don't
know if I I'm going to go through every
actor cuz it's pretty much all of them
but yeah it's another family member with
his big list of actors now we discovered
that long fellows is actually rodri and
his sister's father their mother worked
as a secretary at the company he runs
and the pair had an affair which created
the children they were shut out from
their father's home and literally walled
out of it which came to affect rodri in
the future he ends up having several
children with several women but rather
than shutting them out he decides to
welcome them all in family is a very
important Motif throughout a lot of
Flanigan's work and he often sent his
episodes around certain members to tell
their stories this is something we saw
in things like Haunting of Hill House
and it works really well in the series
to introduce us all to the characters
now rck and melin's mother is struck
down with a mysterious illness and after
they mistakenly bury her she ends up
rising from the grave like a zombie she
ends up killing their father and then
dies herself leaving the two of them
purely against the world now we see a
lot of the backstory of rodri and his
sister as they make their way to the top
of the company running a pharmaceutical
Empire this is clearly riing on Purdue
with rodri introducing a new
prescription drug into the market this
is called liadon with it working as a
standing for Oxycontin even down to it
riffing on the No More Pain tagline
destroying countless lives all in the
name of profit theyve managed to amass
an Empire that's made them almost
indestructible however this is about the
fall of Usher and we see as the family
are taunted by that mysterious woman
Vera now though she's seen as the
personification of death I actually
think there's another potential we could
have here verer is a word that means
spring green and there is the
possibility that she might even be
mother nature huge shout outs to Mo from
the streamer who told me about this
Theory and after thinking about it it
does make a lot of sense verer is also
an anagram of Raven which is probably
the most famous thing in all of Po's
work we learn that she's been part of
major Empires throughout history where
people have gone on to do great things
she doesn't necessarily represent death
because she offers people deals and in
exchange they give up the collateral of
something that they love thus I think it
goes beyond just being the that thing
and instead I think she's more of a
straightforward supernatural being you
could even liken her to a God as first
she giveth then she taketh with her
being a direct force of karma I've seen
people say that she's a demon but I also
think she has a kind of side to her and
she clearly relishes in people doing
well now we discovered that on New
Year's Eve she offered the siblings a
deal in which they could live lavish
Lifestyles but their children would
inherit the debt this would end the
Usher Bloodline with her killing all
those connected to the peir in sometimes
comedic and ironic ways for example we
see Prospero being brought in because of
how fortunate has messed up the
environment in the end he's killed by
what's basically acid rain which makes
the punishment definitely fit the crime
my man the cat killer is killed by a cat
and and all the heart surgery stuff yeah
you can draw the connections now I'm
leaning more towards the force of nature
God Demon angel devil thing but if you
have another theory I'd love to hear
your thoughts on who you think she
really is she two brings up what the
other characters could have been in
other lives and might be death or the
devil or even something we haven't me
mentioned fortunado that means lucky and
she may even be the personification of
luck as she gives people lots of wealth
and riches but it's also unlucky as well
cuz cuz she kills them unlucky mate and
but she does line out the deaths and
also revives Rodrick when he tries to
take himself out there's definitely this
air of mystery to the entire thing with
it's also hearing about an informant in
the family that doesn't actually exist
now this video is sponsored by gold buug
the new fitness family regime that get
you built like my man bu t b calories
quick sell your soul and change your
life so that your wife or mistress feels
great when she's having dinner with you
all you have to do is enter the code
Bill T get 20% off our checkout and
course your soul as well but yeah I'll
see you on that now as things ramp up we
studle in more about rodri's past and
how he was initially part of the expose
rodri's signature had been forged by his
boss in August contacted him as a way to
bring the company's misdeeds to light
working tirelessly they constructed his
testimony but at the last minute rod
flipped and said he signed the forms
this got him a lot of Goodwill at the
company and he's promised the World by
his boss Rufus Rufus is s of someone I
see as being a kin to Vera but he's more
of a literal evil whereas she's just
symbolic appearing as a Gest that
throughout due to what he wears on his
final night this metaphorically
represents chaos Rufus is a man that
rodri will end up becoming with his
Focus solely being on money no matter
the cost now Rufus was willing to use
rodk because he was happy to have
Stooges this is kind of the same way
rodri's willing to use his kids as
leverage and make that deal where he
he's just basically using his family
throughout the series we also get
teasers towards something being buried
behind a wall in the basement of
fortunado which we later learn is indeed
Rufus this ties back to the opening of
the series in which Pink Floyd's Another
Brick in the Wall place that song was
about taking down authority figures
which they're ending with Rufus
represents after taking the fall at the
company rodri's in the right place at
the right time time to take over Rufus
actually offers them jobs like the COO
which they end up getting from verer and
it's kind of wild how much foreshadowing
that there is throughout the series
still though they go ahead with sealing
them in but the pair need to have an
alibi and thus they head out to a bar
which is where they meet Vera making a
deal with the devil where they'll never
be caught they end up also gaining
enormous wealth for them and their
family the series very much asks
questions of greed and selfishness and
whether it's worth destroying others to
get material things is it worth your
quote unquote soul and yes seeing the
two take the deal is played as a mistake
now they're told that they came into the
world together and that they have to go
out together too both in the book and
show meline and rodri are twins with it
being more more sort of a revealing the
source material and what it is here
there's also a lot of nods to POS work
like Bells black cats and Ravens with
these symbols of death lining the entire
series Lenor plays a big part along with
the Raven and the words never more which
also appear too I love how mine makes an
AI but that copies some on social media
posts and after Lenor dies it just keeps
texting Nevermore Now The Narrative of
Arthur Gordon Pim was Po's only complete
novel and that's centered around a great
Expedition similar to what we hear the
character's backstory to be played by
Mark Hamill he's their right-hand man
who too gets offered a deal that he's
strong enough to turn down this is
because he doesn't have any attachments
and he's kind of as shallow as the rest
of the ushers are
he's given up his life to basically gain
nothing important which I feel is
reflected in the other characters Taman
is about a conqueror Napoleon comes from
the spectacles victorine comes from the
premature burial based on her name which
I'm skipping because I can't pronounce
that her name Eliza is named after post
real life mother Augustus may be a n of
the pale blue eye though I could be
wrong on that and Camille is also
someone from the murders in the room
morg the last major one I could find was
rodri's original wife Annabelle Lee
which too was a poem crafted by po this
gets read aloud in the series and it
centers around two people who were so in
love that the higher Powers became
jealous and punish them with death I'm
sure there's other characters in the
series too that are based on his work so
if there's any names I miss then please
drop them below anyway we learn that
after taking the fall that rodri's
marriage never recovered and that the
kids ended up going to him because he
offered money and power the ghost of
Annabelle Lee even Ponders that the
children might have died in their
childhood which we know happened due to
the deal that their dad made in the end
it leaves just meline and rodri with
Leno's death breaking the lad's heart
getting a visual representation of his
body count he watches the Pyramid of
wealth that he's built laid out before
him the Pharaohs were of course buried
with their possessions with this
metaphors are carrying over to what
happens with meline she ends up going to
meet with him for a drink but soon
realizes that he's drugged it using
mummification techniques to preserve her
he ends up attempting to send her off
like an Egyptian queen however she Rises
and attacks him whilst the house
crumbles around them and it comes
crashing down killing both Madeline and
rodri now Aus manages to make it out and
he sees Vera standing on the top of
Empire from here we see the consequences
playing out and Le what happened with
the other characters Arthur is given the
20 a that Vera promised him in the deal
and Leno's promised Legacy plays out too
we learn that her mother set up a
foundation in her name and that decades
later it had saved millions and millions
of lives Juno managed just to get
herself off the drug and she sets
something up known as the Phoenix
Foundation this actually ties him with
Arthur as he was told he could be Like a
Phoenix Rising From the Ashes he was
also told though that he could end up
watching a fly away which is something
that ends up happening now jeta Kamil
keeping a file on him and this is
discovered and all of his misdeeds are
brought to the light he's very much a py
just like how rodri was with him being
the only character who gets convicted
from the Scandal nowas ends up visiting
the family Brave site and he says he's
going home to his husband kid and their
kids saying he's the richest man in the
world we get the true idea of wealth
being in family and not the material
things they were somewhat buried amongst
vitu visits the graves and leaves the
material and superficial things they
coveted which shows the family really
lost out in the end their need for power
and wealth has cost them it all with the
family being brought down from within by
their own greed it's a cautionary tale
about what the true cost of selling
one's Soul can bring and in the end that
closes out the series now as for my
thoughts on the series I think this was
another Masterpiece from Mike with it
being all the things he'd learned from
his previous projects rolled into one
man has conquered the family formula and
though that sometimes means it's
formulaic he's still knocking it out the
park to the point I can't really ding it
for being similar to what he's done
before what I was really impressed by
the m is how he's managed to even pretty
much all of Po's work into one seamless
narrative that doesn't feel forced this
is very very much a love letter to him
and they beautifully encapsulate
everything about the author into one
piece that flows really well I can't
imagine how difficult that would be but
to bring it together as neatly as this
was no easy task you also have the
characters too that feel like real
fleshed out people and again flanakin
has brilliantly cast younger and older
versions of the same characters expertly
I personally think that midnight mass
and horning of Hill House are above this
but to me they were some of the best
shows I'd ever seen and this still ranks
really high so if you prefer it then I'm
not going to be mad at you I can easily
see how you'd love this and he's managed
to once more make a horror show that has
a soul in it and goes beyond just being
cheap jump scares There's real terror
here but Beauty too and all in all it's
about how damaging greed can be there's
lots of real world metaphors you can
apply to it too and they even sneak some
digs in there at former presidents and
corporate heads but we'll not get into
that still though with the key theme
being family I'm sure there's lots
who'll be able to relate to this even if
we're watching multi-billionaires doing
the most horrible things this is because
that message is so strong and The Fall
of the House of user I think was a
brilliant achievement Flanagan has done
it again I can't praise the show high
enough and yeah this this is clearly the
best guy working in horror right now he
manages to balance the characters
emotion horror everything perfectly and
yeah it's difficult to not score this
show very highly there are some things
that I felt you know they could have
maybe Ted Ed up the pacing a bit but all
in all this was a brilliant series to
watch I'm going to give it a 9 out of 10
but that may go up or down depending on
how I feel after rewatches it's
something I'm sure I'm going to go back
to as there was so many details in it
and yeah I can't wait to see what the
guy does next obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you drop them
in the comments below please like the
video as well and if you want to support
the channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
they're helping us out you want to get
some heavy spoilers merch we've also got
our t-shirt line located just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house of dragon stuff lowy te's and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out for them and I'll see you on the
next one now if you want something else
to watch we've got a video on screen
right now so definitely head over there
right after this by the way huge thank
you for sing through the video I've been
Paul and I'll see you next time you take
care peace